new in theaters this weekend Shazam Pet
Sematary and the best of enemies what
will you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
yeah you electrocuted a bus and who must
kill these people and then I caught it
Zachary Levi as a superhero the coolest
this movie follows the story of 14 year
old Billy Batson who one day gets on the
Philadelphia subway that somehow takes
him to an ancient wizard dwelling realm
and is given superpowers by saying the
word Shazam Billy transforms into a
cape-wearing adult superhero Shazam
didn't work still kale I'd like to
purchase some of your finest beer please
[Music]
this movie is for you if you like comedy
superhero movies you find coming-of-age
movies with a Tom Hanks in big twist
super powerful or Shazam and leap tall
buildings in a single bound
in the woods today LA discovered a
charming little land work
but Pet Sematary also out this weekend
Pet Sematary this supernatural horror is
the second adaptation of the Stephen
King novel with the first being the 1989
film so many trees it's beautiful right
it's definitely not Boston when dr.
Lewis and Rachael Creed relocate their
family to rural Maine they discover a
pet cemetery /ii both ancient burial
ground in the woods behind their home
it's not creepy at all
there's something up there those woods
belong to something else fun fact thanks
to the spelling of the title of this
movie I've never been confident on how
to spell the word cemetery it's filled
with a/c thanks Stephen this movies for
you if you're a fan of the original
anything Stephen King gives you the
creeps and you like it or you've ever
built something on an ancient burial
ground last night an electrical fire
destroyed East End Elementary School
Fair we're gonna go to school now go
head back kids going to Tim school we're
finally out this weekend the best of
enemies taraji P Henson and Sam Rockwell
co-star and this emotional drama about
racial segregation tensions in 1971
Durham North Carolina we gonna be school
segregation once and for all civil
rights activist and Atwater played by
taraji and KKK leader C pls played by
Sam agree to co-chair a community
meeting discussing school dissing the
unlikely duo find themselves at the
forefront of a very important time in
American history as long as the CP
Alice's of the world keep getting they
away ain't nothing gonna change she
looked at me I got some gossip
why do you expect this movie is for you
if you like historical dramas about the
civil rights movement or you're
impressed by the acting chops of taraji
P Henson and Sam Rockwell that is your
weekend ticket what will you see and
check back next week for a little movie
Shazam
come on
[Music]
[Music]